[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 tout de suite les
titres de ce mardi 31 octobre une
période de léger répit la trêve
hivernale débute demain jusqu'au 31 mars
2018 la loi empêche l'expulsion d'un
locataire de son logement
ce qui n'empêche pas les associations de
se mobiliser pendant cette trêve et nous
recevons caroline lejard animatrice du
secours catholique dans les yvelines et
gérard paul membre de solidarité
nouvelles pour le logement yvelines
établissement public d'aménagement
agglomération beaucoup de structures et
de collectivités portent l'appellation
paris saclay et dans cette multitude des
chenaux difficile de s'y retrouver
de quoi parle-t-on concrètement
chronique dans ce journal enfin c'est
halloween aujourd'hui vous allez
peut-être fêter cet événement question
fatidique
quels costumes allez-vous à choisir pour
fêter dignement halloween
tour d'horizon à la fin de cette édition
dans une boutique de déguisements à mort
pas de la politique pour débuter ce
journal avec une nouvelle fonction pour
didier baichère le député la république
en marche de la première circonscription
des yvelines a été désigné par son
groupe
il sera le porte parole des
parlementaires et les rues m lors des
discussions sur le budget défense à
l'assemblée nationale une commission sur
le sujet se tient ce jeudi lé débat en
séance publique se tiendront à eux dès
mardi prochain et du monde autour de moi
sur ce plateau nicolas acquis hrenovica
de la rédaction de tv 60,18 vous nous
parler
dans un instant vous nous aidez pardon à
y voir un peu plus clair sur paris
saclay ça sera dans un instant mais tout
de suite on parle dans ce journal de la
trêve hivernale elle débute demain pour
une durée de cinq mois
pendant cette période la loi prévoit
qu'un locataire ne peut se faire
expulser de son logement bonsoir à
caroline le charme ça vous est
animatrice et du secours catholique dans
les yvelines et bonsoir gérard paul je
suis membre de solidarité nouvelles pour
le logement tout à fait j'allais vous
allez vous présenter contre un instant
bonsoir à vous membres de solidarité
nouvelles pour le logement yvelines et
vous êtes également donc vous occuper la
fonction de trésorier vous êtes
également le responsable d'un groupe
local snl à fontenay le fleury
alors avant de parler de la trêve
hivernale petit tour de table sur les
missions de chacun caroline lejard
quelle est l'action du secours
catholique dans les yvelines combien de
personnes sont aidées par l'association
ya environ 14000 personnes aidées chaque
année par nos équipes locales environ
2000 bénévoles qui sont répartis dans
les dents lisant le tout est divine
voilà pour des actions d'accompagnement
d'accueil et aussi des missions plutôt
de lien social d'entr'aide et renforcer
le pouvoir d'agir des gens j'ai un peu
le côté snl vous vous engagez vous pour
rendre le logement accessible aux
personnes en situation de précarité
l'idée c'est de créer du logement
cet argument avec des moyens extrêmement
limités puisque le parc de logements des
yvelines pour snl ses 115 logements avec
beaucoup de projets mais beaucoup de
projets difficiles à à mener au bout un
projet c'est à dire un logement ou deux
ces trois ans d'accord beaucoup de temps
pour mettre tout ça en fait c'est vous
avez une idée de combien de personnes
qui sont en situation de précarité
nous accueillons la particularité de snl
pas seulement à ses dribbles il met les
snf départementale d'île de france
c'est d'accueillir des familles en
difficulté de les accompagner pendant 18
mois 2 ans un peu plus d'accord
quelquefois moins jusqu'à un logement
pérenne avec cette particularité d'un
double accompagnement par un travailleur
social
salariés de l'association et par les
équipes locales
dont je suis un des responsables
affronter le fleury alors je vais dit la
trêve hivernale débute demain qui en
ligne le jard pour bien faire comprendre
ce que c'est la trêve la trêve hivernale
à nos téléspectateurs pendant cette
période où il concrètement un locataire
ne peut pas être exclue de son jeu va
être expulsé de son logement
effectivement normalement un allocataire
ne veut pas être exclue de son logement
c'est la loi qui prévoit la loi qui
prévoit ça c'est une mesure qui a été
prise en 1956 suite à l'appel le coup de
gueule de l'abbé pierre en 54 il ya
quand même des restrictions on peut
expulser une personne cil à cil objet si
le logement fait l'objet d'un péril pour
le locataire ou si une solution
d'urgence fin une solution plutôt de
logements pérennes qui est proposée
derrière mais que quelques quelques
exceptions et là des coups c'est la même
manière c'est on ne coupe pas aussi le
gaz et l'électricité
elle ne concerne pas uniquement le la
défense locale la location elle pensait
un également les factures électriques
s'ils ne sont pas payées on ne peut pas
couper les l'énergie aux personnes en
revanche les démarches elle de procédure
d'expulsion continue pendant sept ans à
dire qu'elles sont uniquement suspendu
elle serait dès le 1er avril
effectivement et du coup dû signer
mesure d'expulsion est prononcé pendant
cette période elle ne prend fin elle ne
prend enfin l'un d'eux prend acte si
c'est qu'après le comté 31 massa alors
gérard paul est ce qu'il ya une
mobilisation particulière de vous
pourrez sennels pendant cette période
hivernale
non parce que
les familles les familles que nous
accueillons nous sont envoyées sur sur
dossier par les services sociaux
d'accord et a priori nous ne sommes pas
concernés directement par cette
interruption nous n'avons pas d'afflux
spécifique pendant la période où les
expulsions sont autorisés et le
l'interruption pour nous n'a pas de n'a
pas d'effet nous nous situons sur le
traitement du mal logement
même sur un créneau très très spécifique
est beaucoup plus petit qu par exemple
qu habitat humanisme oud ou d'autres
plus importants nous nous situons sur
sur ce créneau où nous agissons tout au
long de l'année sans que la trêve
hivernale et le moindre effet sur sur
notre action
elie positif ni négatif et pour le
secours du coup catholique
comment ça se passe que quel travail est
mis en place pendant particulièrement
cette trêve hivernale
c'est un peu différent parce que comme
on agit essentiellement sur les causes
on va profiter de ce sursis pour voir un
petit peu avec les personnes pourquoi il
ya des impayés
on va essayer de voir qui c'est le loyer
qu'il est trop élevé aussi c'est les
factures énergétiques qui ont été trop
élevé s'il ya une surcharge de sulfate
surfacturation des charges par le
bailleur donc ça va être un temps où on
va on va prouver enfin on va profiter
pour négocier avec le bailleur pour
interpeller aussi les pouvoirs publics
pour avoir plus de logement voilà c'est
un temps
un peu propice à la rencontre avec les
personnes pour essayer de les
accompagner au mieux dans une 1re
logements à la fin de cette trêve
hivernale le sas pour les personnes qui
ont un logement et au contraire pour
ceux qui sont mal logés qui vivent dans
la rue c'est aussi peut-être chercher un
hébergement d'urgence
oui parce qu'en fait ce qu'on dit pense
qu'on n'a pas vraiment dit mais on la
renvoie dans le reportage un moment
donné il ya hôtel effectivement il ya
énormément d'expulsion qui se font juste
avant la trêve hivernale
là actuellement il ya une l'évacuation à
montigny du bidonville notamment dont
avec des personnes qui sont logés dans
les hôtels
on chiffre je crois à 15000 personnes
évacuées le mois qui précède la trêve
hivernale donc il va y avoir tout un
accompagnement des personnes dans les
hébergements d'urgence qui sont faits
toute l'année mais davantage
effectivement période hivernale un petit
tour de table très rapide avant de clore
cet entretien une question un peu
ouverte la trêve hivernale est ce que
finalement cette période de répit n'est
n'est pas un trompe l'oeil qui éludent
autre question celle du mal logement et
celle du manquement rappelle que en
france plus de cent quarante mille
personnes vivent dans la rue est ce que
c'est votre gérard paul votre votre
sentiment
c'est un trompe l'oeil c'est
indispensable sur un plan sur un plan
humain mais ça ne résout strictement
rien du problème du logement
il est exactement le même avant la trêve
hivernale
après la trêve hivernale et pendant la
trêve hivernale et on a probablement
tort de penser qu'il est plus facile de
vivre à la rue en été qu'en hiver
caroline le genre très rapidement bah
enfin je rejoins tout à fait rare en
fait c'est enfin
on a aujourd'hui un encombrement du
dispositif d'urgence est pourquoi il ya
un encombrement du dispositif d'urgence
et parce qu'un certain nombre de
personnes qui sont hébergés dans des
hôtels pourraient prétendre à un
logement social
or ya pas assez de logement social il
faudrait en construire on dit cinquante
mille par an pour voilà pour pouvoir
répondre aux besoins de la population
française donc on est loin de ça et
communes n'applique pas suffisamment la
loi sru non plus qui on les oblige à
avoir 20% de logement social par commune
et rien que dans les yvelines ya des
écarts assez important c'est toujours
les mêmes communes où se concentre le
logement social les moins dans les
communes riches voilà donc il ya un
manque de logement social qui entraînent
un engorgement du système d'urgence
merci à vous deux pour vous répondre je
rappelle caroline lejard animatrice du
secours catholique des yvelines et
gérard paul membre de solidarité
nouvelles pour le logement yvelines une
véritable silicon valley à la française
ce projet verra t'il le jour sur le
plateau de saclay en déplacement la
semaine dernière sur ce territoire
emmanuel macron a confirmé qu'un pôle
d'excellence scientifique et
universitaire allait être scindé en deux
objectif relancer le projet alors que
des établissements rechigne à se fondre
dans un modèle commun à nicolas qui
allait aux vitz avant d'apporter une
réponse sur sur l'avenir du dossier
dites-nous déjà de quoi parle-t-on
concrètement quand on évoque paris
saclay c'est vrai qu'on a du mal à s'y
retrouver
oui bien grégory déjà il faut rappeler
qu on évoque un projet assez anciens qui
va fêter bientôt et ses dix ans et dont
l'acte de naissance remonte en fait sous
l'ère nicolas sarkozy qualité président
c'était en 2002 cette année là le projet
paris saclay devient opération d'intérêt
national ce qui permet en clair à
l'époque à l'état d'avoir les coudées
franches en matière d'urbanisme sur une
partie du plateau de saclay objectif de
cette ancienne comme on dit aussi
permettre l'émergence d'un cluster comme
diraient les anglo saxons en français ça
donne un pôle d'excellence pour réunir
sur un seul et même territoire les
meilleures écoles les meilleures
universités les entreprises les plus
innovantes et de nombreux chercheurs
bref vous l'avez compris et vous l'avez
dit en introduction
une silicon valley à la française pour
façonner le monde de demain et pour
façonner ce monde de demain justement
nicolas l'état vu les choses en grand en
effet aujourd'hui le projet paris saclay
s'étend sur deux départements l'essonne
et les yvelines comprend trois
communautés d'agglomération communautés
paris saclay versailles grand parc et
saint-quentin-en-yvelines 27 communes et
couvre au total une superficie de 229
kilomètres carrés et le coeur du projet
désormais c'est l'université paris
saclay là aussi les chiffres sont
impressionnants 70 mille étudiants sur
l'université onze mille chercheurs 18
établissements et en tout 15 % de la
recherche française
une véritable machine de guerre armé
pour la compétition internationale
mais pourtant nicolas et ce projet a
tourné au ralenti depuis quelques mois
et oui parce que le problème quand on
veut faire cohabiter 18 établissements
différents
eh bien ces missions presqu'impossible
chacun de ces établissements est
historique et ne souhaitent pas
forcément aller au bout du processus
d'intégration pour permettre donc au
projet de continuer à avancer mais ne le
maquereau à utiliser il ya une semaine
en déplacement la carte du pragmatisme
deux pôles désormais vont voir le jour
le premier sous la bannière toujours
paris saclay avec les université de
paris sud versailles saint quentin et
ivry et certaines grandes écoles comme
le msk chaud et un autre paul là
uniquement avec des grandes écoles dont
polytechnique est aussi paristech
il y aura donc une forme de cohabitation
sur le même territoire
la cohabitation de baigorri parfois ça
peut bien se passer parfois ça peut très
mal se passer aussi
merci à nicolas pour cet éclairage sur
ce sujet il faut le dire complexe et
dans l'actualité du jour une rencontre
inter générationnel au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines 15 jeunes du
club de l'étoile sportive de trace est
un club de football ont passé la journée
sur place en compagnie de 15 personnes
âgées de la ville
au programme visites
des lieux présence lors des répétitions
d'un spectacle
l'objectif de cette sortie organisée par
l'association format citoyens s'ouvrir à
d'autres disciplines et aussi renforcer
la solidarité
propos recueillis par patrick jacques de
dixmude et mickaël aînés d'euros le foot
est en réalité un loisir important mais
également un prétexte pour faire passer
des messages des messages importants
celui de la solidarité celui des valeurs
de la république qu'on transmet dans
chacun de nos actes au quotidien de nos
valeurs de nos entraînements et
aujourd'hui venir au théâtre c'est une
manière de dire il ya le sport et à la
culture tous qui traverse un être et qui
le fait grandir et qu'il le fait
s'ouvrir au monde
bonsoir alexandre morlaix bonsoir vous
êtes donc le secrétaire général de
l'oefe entrepreneurs à venir france mais
également yvelinois vous êtes venu nous
parler de la création de cette
association elle est composée
d'entrepreneurs et d'acteurs économiques
français à qui donc cette association
défend les valeurs de l'entreprise
auprès de décideurs publics et au sein
aussi à de la société civile beaucoup
d'élus yvelinois vous ont rejoint dans
cette démarche des députés et des
sénateurs
pourquoi avoir lancé cette association
alors en fait à l'issue de l'élection
présidentielle françois fillon avait
créé forces républicaines qui était une
une grosse institution dans laquelle se
situe un certain nombre de think tank ef
on faisait partie les entrepreneurs avec
fillon les femmes avec figureront les
écologistes a dit filion ccf était alors
à l'avant entrepreneurs avec peter fill
avenue entrepreneurs à venir france
était à l'origine effectivement d'un
groupement d'individus qui ont participé
à la création du programme économique
liée au développement et la croissance
des entreprises des tpe puisqu'il faut
savoir que 97% des entreprises en france
sont des tpe et que bah il fallait
absolument redresser la situation
économique
diminuer les charges qui pèsent sur le
dos des sociétés est vraiment créé
j'allais dire un programme participatif
au niveau national puisque les
problématiques j'allais dire d'illinois
sont différentes de celles des lyonnais
ou des bordelais alors à l'origine de ce
mouvement national vous êtes beaucoup de
proches de françois fillon c'est ça oui
tout à fait à l'origine effectivement au
dedans on peut compter 10 giquello qui
est notre président on a également
gérard it is eric lemaire qui sont les
vice présidents on peut compter
également sur muriel regus qui nous a
rejoint qui était la fondatrice des
femmes
avec fillon qui donc a développé tout un
réseau d'entrepreneurs au féminin nous
on est vraiment ici pour défendre des
valeurs auxquelles on croit au caire
certains politiques certains groupements
comme les républicains et autres ont
décidé de renoncer à l'issue de la
présidentielle et nous on souhaite
alimenter au travers de notre think tank
de débats d'idées bas tout ce qui se
passe au travers des régions parce que
c'est pas qu'une île de france qui doit
diriger les choses c'est vraiment un
think tank nationale et on parlait de
think tank est ce qu'on entend par cette
enquête avait bien c'est un laboratoire
d'idées en fait tout est effectivement
tout le monde peut confronter son point
de vue tout le monde peut dialoguer on a
fait récemment une première réunion avec
hervé novelli qui a accepté d'être notre
parrain de aef qui ça vous avez deux
parents voilà on a effectivement réservé
novelli et puis bruno retailleau qui
nous suit également de très près puisque
on
on intervient en qualité de partenaires
aussi bien pour la fondation concorde
hervé novelli que des républicains que
de bruno retailleau sein de forces
républicaines parce qu'aujourd'hui on
n'est pas affilié à un parti on est un
groupement
donnez de femmes qui voulons
effectivement agir pour le compte des
sociétés quelles sont vos ambitions
j'allais vous vous lancez dassieu nos
ambitions c'est de continuer à faire
prospérer ce programme économique était
vraiment fabuleux très riche on a envie
de le faire vivre au travers des
différentes fédérations qu'on a recréé
au sein des régions lyonnaise paca
auvergne occitanie ile de france on a
même le benelux avec nadine vincent veut
vraiment que j'allais dire finalement
les oubliés de la campagne que tous les
petits entrepreneurs parce que ce sont
ceux qui créent le lien social avec avec
les gens aujourd'hui beaucoup d'auto
entrepreneur de professions libérales de
professionnels de la santé ont été
oubliés pendant cette campagne sont
oubliés aujourd'hui dans le programme
économique d' emmanuel macron et je
pense que si on veut faire décoller la
france bat on est obligé de le faire
avec un programme dont j'allais dire
réel concrets issus du terrain et que
les gens vivent au quotidien et pas une
présomption de faits qui ont été jetés
sur un papier dernière chose vos
prochaines manifestations qu'a lieu avec
elles sont elles alors nous en avons une
le jeudi 9 novembre à paris la brasserie
lipp autour de muriel reus qui va nous
parler de l'entrepreneur au féminin
puisque c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on
parle beaucoup du mot entrepreneur on le
voit très masculin aujourd'hui autant
d'entrepreneuses que deux entrepreneurs
il faut le savoir et donc c'est très
important de relancer le principe de la
femme au sein de team tente parce qu'on
a vraiment envie aujourd'hui que d'égal
à égal on puisse parler de du domaine de
l'entreprise qu'on puisse partager et
qu'on puisse aussi ben résoudre ce
problème d'inégalité salariale qui
existe dans des grandes entreprises ont
dans des pme où on ne sait pas pourquoi
le salaire d'une femme serait moins
élevé que celui d'un homme au travers
d'un travail équivalents et d'une charge
de travail qui ne peut pas se mesurer
donc pour moi c'est important
aujourd'hui que l'on conçoit tous sur un
pied d'égalité
merci alexandre barrelet d'avoir été
avec nous je le rappelle vous êtes le
secrétaire général de fo
cette association qui s'appelle donc
entrepreneurs à venir france merci
d'avoir été avec nous suite de notre
série de la semaine le dossier de la
rédaction consacrée au marché de l'après
vie
les yvelines nous nous intéressons ce
soir au cours d'un enterrement et ses
différentes dépenses c'est cercueil
urnes fleurs ou encore maison funéraire
les détails avec michael et demi d'euros
le marché de l'après vie représente en
france à 870 millions d'euros dans les
yvelines cette entreprise de pompes
funèbres implantée à magny les hameaux
en terre chaque année entre 200 et 230
personnes pour répondre à cette demande
la structure propose un service tout
inclus avec notamment transport de corps
maison funéraire l'organisation des
obsèques des prestations qui ont un coût
lorsque nous additionnons un petit peu
tous toutes ses prestations
eh bien on peut on peut très facilement
se retrouver entre 4000 euros et cinq
six sept huit mille euros s'il ya besoin
de la fabrication d'un caveau par
exemple on peut toujours avoir un prix
moins cher
bien évidemment mais tout dépend de la
prestation que l'on offre en face
l'entreprise propose dans ses murs des
stèles des cercueils pour un coût
compris entre 600 et 2600 euros et des
urnes pour la crémation
après c'est un peu idiot crémation donc
nous pouvons mettre nous pouvons
utiliser ces urnes et nous avons ici
plusieurs modèles d'urnes il y a des
urnes biodégradables des urnes en résine
des urnes en métal des urnes en bois
aussi voilà nous commençons à 45 euros
puis ensuite on peut retrouver des urnes
à 200 250 euros pour les urnes en bois
autre marche est impacté par les
enterrements celui des fleurs chez ce
fleuriste installée à montigny le
bretonneux on réalise entre 5 et 6
préparation floral par mois pour des
obsèques 5 à 10% du chiffre d'affaires
annuel
la semaine dernière j'en ai eu à 150
euros ça va entre 150 206 et un comité
d'entreprise qui prend pour un employé
ça peut aller jusqu'à 250 300 points on
essaye de faire au mieux pour garnir le
plus possible pour que les gens aient
quand même pour leur argent
un prix conséquent qui s'explique par le
temps passé sur chaque préparation par
les fleuristes un professionnel passe
entre dix et trente minutes pour choisir
les fleurs et pour les assembler
plusieurs minutes sont également nés
c'est ça pour créer le ruban qui sera
installé sur les gerbes donc on a emmené
à où il ya déjà des mots mais tenez on
n'a pas tous les maux quoi donc on est
obligé de prendre certaines led voyez
c'est des arts et créer notre propre
ruban quoi ce qui est ce qui nous prend
un peu plus de temps tout dépend ce
qu'on marque si c'est quelque chose de
course ça va c'est quelque chose
sincères condoléances si on n'a pas de
coupure un client qui rendent pour des
fleurs ou autres faut bien compter dix
minutes pour faire un roman
chaque année en france plus de 600 mille
décès sont enregistrés un marché qui ne
devrait pas mourir dès demain
aujourd'hui c'est halloween vous êtes
sûrement d'ailleurs en train de vous
préparer pour votre soirée ou pour la
chasse aux bonbons et comme chaque année
la question habituelle quel costume
choisir tout en étant original et
effrayant et nous sommes allés voir les
dernières tendances à une dans une
boutique de déguisements à maurepas
patrick jacques de dixmude marie
pannetrat et hasna allouache en vampire
en sorcière ou encore en zombies chaque
année le 31 octobre se pose la question
comment se déguiser pour la soirée
d'halloween accessoires en tout genre
maquillage effrayant dents de vampires
ou encore hache ensanglantée les petits
comme les grands ne recule devant rien
pour effrayer leurs proches boucher
charcutier
c'est vraiment très bien alors j'ai eu
un choix et j'ai découpé une jungle
c'est sympa ça peut faire peur aux gens
de leur demander des bonbons s'ils
veulent pas mourir dans les rayons il y
a l'embarras du choix
les clients recherchent la tenue la plus
terrifiante je la trouvais alors c'est
quoi
je sais pas trop on verra ses
maquillages qui fait tousser important
halloween brouille comme ça d'autres
misent davantage sur les accessoires
pour terroriser leur voisinage
j'ai des bonbons au chaos je ferai pas
peur à tout le monde mais j'ai des tas
piqûre des squelettes qui s'allument je
vais avoir des toiles d'araignées la
chercher en fait des espèces de grands
sacs en tête de mort pour remplir de
feuilles mortes des choses comme ça
côté budget vous pourrez exprimer votre
créativité sans faire frissonner votre
porte monnaie avec une tenue complète
pour moins de 40 euros
et cette année la tendance des
déguisements est au clown maléfique
adultes et enfants les masques les
tenues le maquillage c'est vrai qu'on
ait beaucoup aidé aussi par la sortie du
film ça donc tout le monde recherche
vraiment dû du clown effrayant ça le
célèbre clown au ballon qui a terrorisé
toute une génération risque donc
d'envahir vous rue dès ce soir le
portrait de la rédaction consacré une
personnalité du territoire ont fait ce
soir la connaissance de wiljan fille
dont elle gérant du magasin cartier geek
à coignières son quotidien est partagé
entre les personnages de comics ou
encore les jeux vidéo une personnalité
guide qu'il assume totalement
rencontre avec aurélie aux marches la
toux bayou
c'est que vous venez d'entendre n'est
pas une langue imaginaire mais un
vocabulaire utilisé par les joueurs de
magic un jeu de cartes à jouer et à
collectionner qui s'est invité dans la
vie de william fidon lorsqu'il était au
collège
après des études de vente il décide
d'allier sa passion à son métier pour
ouvrir une boutique à coignières dédié à
cet univers mais pas que am intérêt pour
la pop culture que l'on retrouve
naturellement chez lui une collection de
1200 dvd ou encore des figurines
mordelles trônant fièrement au dessus de
sa télévision
c'est mon univers préféré c'est le plus
large c'est le plus complet avec les
personnages de plus intéressant ils ont
réussi à approfondir beaucoup de
personnages et ils ont réussi à en faire
certains un peu bizarre comme des poules
qui sort complètement du nom qu'un
véritable antihéros cinéma séries jeux
vidéo
les rappels en lien avec sa passion sont
nombreux dans son salon même s'il a dû
se limiter
c'est seul endroit où j'ai le droit
d'installer il ya un an il ya une petite
pièce encore en fait ma femme a laissé
le les toilettes pour redécorer les
toilettes du bac j'ai fait à star wars
c'était une de mes deux grandes passions
dans le cinéma c'est star wars et ça m'a
permis en fait d'avoir une petite pièce
en plus une passion ancré dans la peau
comme en témoigne ce tatouage que les
fans du jeu vidéo zelda reconnaîtront
mais au fait qu'en pense son entourage
c'est une passion qui suit autant le
professionnel que le personnel parce que
on vit magic on respire magics et voilà
c'est autant à la boutique à la maison
ça s'arrête jamais vraiment
trois soirs par semaine
will i am organise des tournois magic
qui peuvent durer jusqu'au petit matin
surnommé affectueusement d'ul par ses
clients devenus ses amis il fait
l'unanimité c'est quelqu'un de très
accueillants très amicale et toujours à
l'écouté des joueurs on va dire le cool
man et clients surtout parce que mine de
rien c'est comme une boutique saint
louis le roussillon mais c'est pour ça
que nouvelles comme ça très conviviale
très familiale et peut-être un peu trop
généreux et cette fois peut-être lui
porter préjudice mais bon pour l'instant
on veille un peu sur lui aussi de ce
côté-là bonne pâte
il est vraiment sympa il est vraiment il
cherche toujours à faire plaisir aux
gens s'étant montré qu'ils cherchaient
j'aime vraiment ce que tout le monde
passer un super moment ici on fait une
deuxième famille qui selon certains
vivraient dans une autre galaxie
et pourtant être geek n'est pas une tare
pour williams
bien au contraire c'est simplement être
passionné avoir de réelle passion sur
des univers certes fictif mais avec de
réelles histoire à l'intérieur et en
fait il ya beaucoup de geeks qu'il ne le
pense pas l'être et qui en fait le son
essai en rien quelque chose de mal être
geek en fait c'est juste une passion
il n'y a pas il n'ya pas être péjoratif
ya pas à se sentir mal d'être geek c'est
quelque chose de bien en fait on se
quitte avec ces images sympathiques on
vous parlait tout à l'heure des costumes
pour halloween et bien les animaux aussi
de la spa de plaisir ce sont à déguiser
pour l'événement ils attendent bien sûr
d'être adopté le refuge de plaisir qui
sera ouvert toute la journée de demain
mercredi 1er novembre de 10h30 à 13h et
de 14h à 17h c'est la fin de ce set 8
journal on se retrouve dès jeudi pour
une nouvelle édition d'information
locale sur tv 78 bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]